today's topic white guilt man i didn't
check my feed for a couple of days and i
came back and there was all these posts
like
hey uh white people we see you if you're
not posting about this you're the
problem we've seen all kinds of weird
posts like that
i don't think you encourage people to
change their mindset and their behaviors
by shaming them
and if you do live in a position of
privilege it's not by whining about it
and self-flagellating on social media
that you helped me i don't care i'm so
privileged i live in a five-acre home
with five floors and a dad and a mom who
loves me and grandparents who gave me
i don't care i don't care what i i do
want you to do however
is i want you to use that position if
you can to help others
if you understand that you've got a lot
of money and that you care about these
social issues then you find ways to
donate right
i'm not going to tell you you have to do
it i'm not going to tell you what to do
with that stuff but if you want to and
you do have those positions
these are things that you can do don't
moan about your privilege don't try to
get rid of it
if you live in a position of privilege
you help others the same way
i'm an able-bodied person if i see
someone in a wheelchair and they can't
get somewhere i'ma help them
you don't cut off your own legs to be
like i understand you black that's
what you want to buy the fact that you
have legs nobody cares i i don't like
i don't like going on my social media
and watching white people whine about
how good they have it in some cases it's
cringe
stop when this comes out i understand
that you want to
act and that you know especially black
folks they want to be able to do stuff
they want to encourage more changes and
so they're like why people start
listening
it's not by screaming at people that you
get them to understand
you act and you do what you need to do
for you but you don't you can't force
people to change their ways
people are not going to start listening
because you tell them to listen they're
going to start listening because you're
saying powerful things
so go be the change that you want to see
in the world and now for white people
who want to get involved and do feel
some type of way but don't know how
or for other minorities or other groups
who just want to take time to listen
take time to understand take time to
self-reflect
that's the main thing right when the
metoo stuff jumped off right and there
was some crazy things happening
me as a man it took time for me to
reflect and understand like hey maybe
that stuff in the way i engage with
other people
isn't the most appropriate and maybe i
can do better with that you know
and maybe i can be cognizant of the fact
that women do live under certain fears
at night when they're walking home alone
you know
take time to try to understand basically
what it boils down to is try to be a
really good neighbor
it's the best way i could define it uh
just a quick note
these videos these topics that we're
covering they're going to be demonetized
and when they get demonetized that means
it's harder for people to view them
because youtube the algorithm affects it
differently so if you want to be able to
push this message out to more people
you want more people to see the
discussion please start the video hit
the like button make sure that everyone
can see this
so that we can spread this far and wide
leave a comment all that good stuff
alright
and if you're not already subscribed and
you're just watching hit that subscribe
button you know hit that bell so you can
catch these videos
i understand why they're posting that
you know honest i i get what
i don't believe just if i want to answer
your question clearly
what do i think about if white people
don't say anything on their social media
they're part of the problem actually
posting things on your social media
doesn't mean [ __ ]
it doesn't mean that you're the problem
it doesn't mean that you're the answer
so the fact that you're posting
i've seen a lot of people posting [ __ ]
uh
and i've seen a lot of people posting
[ __ ] but being the problem
i'm kind of i'm i'm on the
the fence with this with this part of
the of the subject
because some people some of them white
peoples are listening some people are
doing the right thing
and i also find it super cringy when i
open
my my my social media and i see all
these messages
maybe i find it cringy because it's not
for me but there's other people maybe
that
that when they put this [ __ ] they put
this on because
there are other people their siblings
their people in their family
some of their friends some of the people
that do not think like them
that are not conscious of that and they
put that for them
so i get that yeah so i'm really on i'm
really on the edge
i'm not totally on one side totally on
the other one side but i understand both
maybe one of the first step where you
don't know how to do things you know
after you post that don't just post that
to post that and say
hey my job is done here i feel good
about myself because i posted that
message
so i'm good they know i'm not about that
life then that don't mean [ __ ] they
don't do that
if you just stop it at that and that was
your way to you know
oh my god there's people in africa dying
and then you pose that just to feel good
about yourself
or furthermore you go to africa to build
something just to feel good about
yourself
and work your ego don't [ __ ] do it
after you've done that and you post it
and you've done that cringey stuff
there's other steps
you do that first step most people are
going to tune you out nobody cares how
much you think your whiteness is bad
nobody cares and when they hear that
they want to stop listening to you
because you sound pathetic
whiteness is not inherently good or evil
how you use it is
so if you say listen this is how i want
to help great but nobody cares to hear
you whip yourself
nobody we're not a bunch of masochists
that want to see you in pain
nobody gives a [ __ ] i get that so i'm on
that side if you want to do that cringy
stuff
do it but i'm going to sit here and be
like this is going to help your friends
if [ __ ] that
no friends and family be like what you
say whiteness is bad this is great i
didn't know
no that's stupid if you want to be
active recognize that one
social media is not inherently real life
it's not
there's plenty of people who are very
active that you know that really bothers
me that sometimes black people do like
and i see who
posted about this and i see who did it
it's not because someone didn't post
about this
that they're not really involved or they
don't really care so you need to also
calm that and slow that down
all right it's not by looking at
someone's social media feed that you
determine what kind of human being they
are
that's that's crazy to me oh you didn't
post about rodney king
yay you a white suprema what the [ __ ] is
you talking about
yet that person could be working at
their local chapter for black rights or
whatever it may be
you don't know so we need to stop
thinking that social media
is reality 100 it's really not
it's really not and we need to look at
more tangible ways to do these things
but again stop trying to impose these
actions on other people you don't bring
change by telling people
you're [ __ ] up change they need to
internalize that themselves
you act you lead by example you do what
you need to do take the actions that you
want to take but don't push that on
other people
i know too many black people that want
to get on social media uh this is what
you need to do [ __ ] what have you done
what have you done other than condemn
white folks what have you done what have
you done for me lately
that's just too much of this it's not
because you're inherently black
for the cause let's get real let's get
real i know plenty of white people who
do far more for black folks
than a lot of black folks so don't sit
here and grandstand like
this is what you need to do here's a
document where you can dismantle your
privilege why would they dismantle their
privilege
if they have a position of power and
they can do good things then have them
help you
this is how you can get rid of your legs
so you could also be in a wheelchair it
sounds stupid doesn't it it does
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm not seeing it
i know a lot of people said i'm looking
at it this wrong way but i want to hear
your thoughts what do you guys think
oh [ __ ] abba you didn't post about you
being black today i guess you're white
according to joe biden
[Music]